حديث عهد نسبيا بالسياسه مع سجل حافل
بالاخفاقات الانتخابيه لكن لكم نصيبا
وافرا من الفرص مهدت له خوض السباق للدخول
القصر الرئاسي من خلفيه برقراطيه ووظيفه
حكوميه انطلق كلش دار اوغلو في الحياه
العامه حتى توليه اداره مؤسسه التامين
الاجتماعي لغايه عام 99 شكل عام 2002 نقطه
تحول في تاريخ الرجل ففيها دخل البرلمان
نائبا عن مدينه اسطنبول وهو القادم من
ولايه شرقي الاناضول حيث ولد عام 48
واسطنبول بما لها من مكانه تاريخيه
وسياسيه فتحت ابواب السياسه واحلامها
للرجل الذي ينحدر من اسره علويه لتمثيل
اسطنبول مره اخرى في البرلمان عام 2007
سجل كيلجار اوغلو بدا بالاخفاقات
الانتخابيه قبل توليه زعامه الحزب حيث خسر
السباق نحو رئاسه بلديه اسطنبول عام 2009
امام مرشح العداله والتنميه العداله
والتنميه ورجب اردوغان بقي عقبه طوال
حياتك السياسيه حتى بعد توليه رئاسه حزب
الشعب الجمهوري عام 2010 عقب فضيحه
اخلاقيه دفعت رئيس الحزب حينها ديليس
بايكال للاستقاله فالرجل قاد المعارضه من
البرلمان والشارع بوجه حكومات العداله
والتنميه المتعاقبه منذ ذلك الحين ومع
خساره حزبه للانتخابات العامه في 2011 و
حجزتار اوغلو مقعدا وطالبه المقام في
المعارضه حتى محاوله ازاحه رجب طيب
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه فشلت رغم
اختيار مرشحين يخطبون ضد التيار المحافظ
مثل اكمل الدين احصاء اوغلو عام 2014
ولاحقا محرم انجا عام 2018
واللافت هنا ان انسحب بشكل غامض من
انتخابات هذه السنه التي قرر خوضها حزب
البلد وبمواجهه كينجدار اوغلو نفسه مما
عمق الشرخ بين قوى المعارضه وهدد بتشتيت
اصواتها اعطت الانتخابات البلديه عام 2019
زخما للمعارضه خصوصا حزب الشعب الجمهوري
الذي فاز مرشحه اكرم امام اوغلو ببلديه
اسطنبول الكبرى بعد هيمنه قاربت ربع قرن
لحزب الرفاه ثم حزب الفضيله ولاحقا
العداله والتنميه وكذلك فوز منصور يفاش
ببلديه انقره الكبرى الا ان هذا الزخم وضع
منافسين جددا للانتخابات الرئاسيه من داخل
الحزب بمواجهتك لجدار اوغلو وهما امام
اوغلو ويفاش الامر الذي اثار خلافا هدد
بانهيار تحالف الشعب او ما يعرف بالطاوله
السداسيه حيث اصرت رئيسه حزب الجيد ميرال
اكشنار على عدم ترشيحك واختيار امام اوغلو
وانتهى الخلاف بتسويه افضت الى اقتراح
رئيسي بلديتي انقره واسطنبول نائبين
محتملين الرئيس وهو من انتشل التح من تفكك
كان وشيكا ورغم العداء السياسي للعداله
والتنميه واردوغان الا انجدار اوغلو اصطف
مع الحكومه بمواجهه محاوله انقلاب عام
2016 والخلاف مع اردوغان لا يختصر على
السياسه الداخليه والاقتصاديه بل يمتد الى
العلاقه مع دول الجوار والتوازنات
الاقليميه والدوليه فكلجدار اوغلو يرفض
مثلا حاله العداء مع النظام السوري ويسعى
لاعاده اللاجئين في اقرب فرصه ممكنه
ويتطلع الى تطوير العلاقه مع اسرائيل
واعاده الجنود الاتراك من قواعد منتشره في
عدد من